On the afternoon of
Thanksgiving 1962,
I decided to start project MAC.
And the next day I
had an appointment
with the provost,
Charlie Townes.
And I told him
what I had in mind,
and I said, well, think
about it and let me know.
And he said, oh, no.
Go ahead.
So encouraged by that
during the weekend,
I wrote a little
memorandum-- two pages.
Then on Monday I did
[INAUDIBLE] around MIT,
and on Tuesday, I went to see
the president, J. Stratton.
And the only question
that he had--
where are you going to do it?
And by that time, I
had done some homework
and find out that the new
building that was being
built in Technology Square.
So there was a
space on Thursday.
Licklider was supposed to come
to MIT for something else,
so everybody got together
in the president's office.
We shook hands, and that was it.
Oh, wow.
Exactly one week.
There were no computer
scientists, after all,
because nobody had a
computer science program yet.
So everybody was a
mathematician, a physicist,
an electrical
engineer, a drop out.
We had them all.
But they had skipped
the analog age.
Every one of them was peculiar,
and different, and unusual,
and maybe artistic, but
whatever they wanted to do
they would get done.
The project that
had to be done was
whatever was the
right thing to do
because I discovered the
right path, and I liked that.
That's the way
science ought to be.
There had been an initial
surge to try to do something
about timesharing.
So I decided to initiate
basically a quick hack
by creating a timesharing
system on using the IBM 709,
but by just basically
using the mechanisms that
had been tacked onto the 709 so
that the operating system could
begin to function as
a time sharing system,
we basically took
a very quick cut
at creating what
came to be called
the compatible
timesharing system.
The hackers worked
on their computers,
but there was all the CTSS,
and the [? many folks, ?]
and others.
The hackers felt
like, by golly, we
got to be able to do
better than they did.
So [INAUDIBLE] initial operating
system was called CTSS,
and so they called there's ITS.
CTSS is compatible
timesharing system,
and ITS was the incompatible
timesharing system, and that
created a culture
among the hackers,
which was really hard to beat.
There was wonderful family.
Several years afterwards
when Project MAC
was really become a laboratory,
I tried to change the name.
The administration
wouldn't let me.
The laboratory was a piece of
a department doing research
into an established area,
and computer science
was regarded as an
established area.
One of the things we did towards
the beginning of Project MAC
was we decided we had to
revise, revamp, and redo
the file system.
That created different
new, unknown atmosphere
in Project MAC.
That is, the computer
system became
a property of the people,
and this was a phenomenon
that we didn't expect.
People tried--
created a community,
and people started writing
a program for other people
to use, which was a new thing.
We had a big memory--
a whole megabyte of RAM.
In my pocket is 10,000
times as much RAM
as Joel had-- as the biggest
computer we had then,
but we were on the
leading edge saying
we need that sort of
thing, and that became
the standard sort of thing.
And I don't think if we
weren't doing that, that that
wouldn't have happened.
We all knew about Moore's law,
and I sort of believed it,
but I can't for the
life of me figure out
why I couldn't have
anticipated what's happened.
I just didn't, and I
don't know whether that
was myopia or what, but
it's all so logical when
you look backwards, and it seems
to happen just on schedule,
but why didn't we predict it?
I don't know.
Well, I think the kinds
of things we did back then
have become part of
mainstream computer science,
and as they become
more important,
they become less conspicuous.
People were shocked.
I mean, there were two things.
One was the idea that
out of a typewriter
you could control the computer.
This was basically
unthinkable for many people.
And then the powering
added to the thing--
what you could do.
It was just a different world
that people were enchanted.